the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I want to do a quick review of what
we did last time because I know I
through think we proved the full six
boards of math and physics at you guys
we started off trying to describe this
general situation if you have a small
nucleus one firing at a large nucleus
two something happens and we didn't
specify what that was a potentially
different nucleus three could come
shooting off at angle theta and a
potentially different nucleus four goes
off at a different angle fee just to
warn you guys before you start copying
everything from the board starting last
week I've been taking pictures of the
board at the end of class so if you
prefer to like look and listen or just
take a few notes rather than copy
everything else down I'll be taking
pictures of the board at the end of
class from now on and posting them to
the stellar site so up to you how you
want to do it we started off with just
three equations we conserve mass energy
and momentum mass and energy let's see
come from the same equation C squared
plus t1 plus m2 c squared plus t2 has to
equal M 3 C squared plus t3 plus M 4 C
squared plus t4
we started off making one quick
assumption that the nucleus to whatever
we're firing things at has no kinetic
energy so we can just forget that what
we also said is that we have to conserve
X&Y momentum so if we say the X momentum
of particle one would be root 2 M 1 T 1
plus 0 for a particle 2 because we the
particle 2 is not moving and has no
momentum has to equal root 2 M 3 T 3
cosine theta because it's the X
component of the momentum plus root 2 M
44 cosine fee and the last equation for
y momentum I'll call this X momentum
call that mass and energy call this Y
momentum
was let's say there's no y momentum at
the beginning of this equation so I'll
just say zero plus zero equals the Y
component of particle freeze momentum
root 2m 3t3 sine theta minus almost did
that wrong because it's going in the
opposite direction root two and 44 sine
fee we did something and we arrived at
the Q equation I'm trying to make sure
we get to something new today so the Q
equation went something like and I want
to make sure that I don't miss write it
at all so when we refer to the Q
equation we're referring to this highly
generalized equation relating all of the
quantities that we see here so I'm not
going to go through all of the steps
from last time
because again you'll have a picture of
the board from last time but a 20 calls
t 1 times M 1 over m 4 minus 1 plus T 3
times 1 plus M 3 over M 4 minus 2 root M
1 M 3 T 1 T 3 cosine theta and last time
we talked about which of these
quantities are we likely to know ahead
of time and which ones might we want to
find out chances are we know all of the
masses involved in these particles
because well you guys have been
calculating that for the last two and a
half weeks or so so those would be known
quantities we'd also know the Q value
for the reaction from conservation of
mass and energy up there and we probably
be controlling the energy of particle 1
as it comes in either we know if it's a
neutron we know at energy its born at or
if it's coming from an accelerator we
crank up the voltage on the accelerator
and control that and that leaves us with
just three quanta two quantities that we
don't know the kinetic energy of
particle three and the angle that it
comes off at
so this was the highly highly
generalized form recognize also that
this is a quadratic equation in root
three or root T three and we did
something else and we arrived at root T
three equals s plus or minus root s
squared plus T or SMT let's see I
believe s is root m1 m3 t1 cosine theta
over m3 + m4 I'll make a little bit more
room T should be named it got a look I
believe it's minus m4 q plus I'll just
take a quick look all right I have it
open right here I don't want to give you
a wrong minus sign or something I did
have a wrong - I'm good thing I looked
be 1 over m 3 4 and so we started
looking at well what are the
implications of this solution right here
for exothermic reactions where Q is
greater than 0 any energy e1 gets this
reaction to occur and all that that says
well it doesn't really say much all that
it really says is that III I'm sorry t3
and let me make sure that I don't use
any sneaky E's in there + t4 has to be
greater than the incoming energy t1
that's the only real implication here is
that some of the mass from particles 1 &
2 turned into some kinetic energy and
particles 3 & 4 so that one's kind of a
simpler case
for the endothermic case where Q is less
than zero there's going to be some
threshold energy required to overcome in
order to get this reaction to occur so
where did we say so first of all where
would we go about deciding what is the
most favorable set of conditions that
would allow one of these reactions to
occur by manipulating parameters in s
and T what's the first one that you'd
start to look at well let's start by
picking the angle let's say if there was
uh if we had what's called forward
scattering then this cosine of theta
equals one and that probably gives us
the highest likelihood of a reaction
happening or the most energy gone into
let's say just moving the center of mass
and not the particles going off in
different directions let's see ah so
what it really comes down to is a
balance and making sure that this term
right here well it can't go negative if
it goes negative then the solutions
imaginary and you don't have anything
going on so what this implies is that s
squared plus T has to be greater or
equal than zero in order for this to
occur otherwise you'd have like I said a
complex solution to an energy and energy
is not going to be complex that means
the reaction won't occur so this is
where we got to last time yep it would
but there's a condition here that let's
see in this case for exothermic Q is
greater than zero and that condition is
always satisfied for an endothermic
reaction Q is negative so that's a good
point
so if endothermic then Q is less than
zero and it's all about making sure that
that some s squared plus T is not
negative what that means is in order to
balance out the fact that you've got a
negative queue here you have to increase
t1 in order to make that sum greater
than or equal to zero yep that's correct
if s squared plus T is smaller than zero
which is to say that this whole sum
right here doesn't help you balance out
the negative Q then the reactions not
going to happen and something else might
happen so let's say you were looking at
a case of inelastic scattering where a
neutron would get absorbed by a nucleus
and be readmitted at a different energy
level if the energy is too small for
that to occur then the neutrons not
going to get absorbed instead it might
bounce off and undergo elastic
scattering and as a quick flash forward
I'll show you a quick plot of a elastic
and inelastic cross-sections that kind
of hammers this home you'll be looking
at a lot of these plots that are going
to be logarithmic in energy space and
probably logarithmic in microscopic
cross-section to bring back that
variable from before if you remember the
cross-section is like the probability
that a certain reaction is going to
occur the larger the cross-section the
higher the reaction rate for a given
flux of particles and let's say we'll
split this into two things we'll call it
Sigma elastic and Sigma inelastic and
we'll give them that'll be uh-oh we have
colors let's just use those even better
where's my second color under the paper
awesome so let's say the elastic
cross-sections in red and the inelastic
cross-sections in green and for white
we'll plot Sigma total usually one of
these cross-sections for any old
interaction I'm not even being specific
on which one let's just say neutrons
hitting something big would tend to look
like this there'll be some insanity here
that we'll discuss and it might start to
increase a little bit as it goes to high
energies and this is definitely not to
scale just for the purposes of
illustration
the elastic cross-sections going to look
something like exactly this see how
closely I can draw on top of it so at
low energy is when a neutron can't be
absorbed and re-emitted at a different
energy the inelastic scattering process
can't happen which is to say that the
incoming kinetic energy so this log of e
right here
better known as T 1 in the symbols up
there it's not high enough to allow
inelastic scattering to occur so if we
want to graph the inelastic scattering
cross-section it'll typically look like
that where once you reach your threshold
energy determined by that condition
there then in the inelastic scattering
like turns on and it's actually able to
proceed so this is why we're getting
into these threshold reactions because
it helps you understand why does some of
the cross-sections that we study have
the shapes that they do and this holds
true for pretty much every inelastic
cross section I've seen is they all
almost all of them if you're starting at
the ground state require some initial
energy input to get going whereas
elastic scattering can happen at any
energy so let's write that last
condition right here elastic scattering
which means things just bounce off like
billiard balls you have Q equals zero no
energy changes hands so to speak you
just get some kinetic energy from one
being imparted to nucleus - but you
don't turn any mass into energy so any
questions here before we go into yep
so the question is if you don't know the
angle what do you do about it right if
you don't so in this case we've said
what is the bare minimum threshold for
this reaction to occur and the best way
that to happen is for theta to equal 0
if theta is larger that will actually
mean that the reactions not allowed to
proceed unless you get to an even higher
energy so this condition still holds but
if cosine so let's say if cosine theta
is less than 1 then the value of s goes
down and that makes this condition
harder to satisfy so that's a good
question what that actually means is
that for certain nuclear reactions very
close to the threshold energy only
certain angles are allowed I'm not going
to get into the nitty-gritty of which
angles are allowed I think it's I'll
call it my new shah for the scope of
this class but it is in the hip reading
which I'll be posting pretty soon but
suffice to say that the only time you
can let's say if s squared plus T equals
0 the only time that can happen is when
theta equals 0 or cosine equals 1 and
that means that the nucleus can only
recoil in a very very narrow cone
forward as that energy increases the
allowable angles start to increase
further design into your question or
you'd say let's say if cosine equals 180
then I'm sorry if theta equals a hundred
eighty cosine would be negative one and
that would be let's say the least
favorable condition yep
oh I'm saying so Sigma elastic plus
sorry Sigma inelastic would let's say
give you the total scattering
cross-section the green line so it is a
little hard to see that the Green Line
is the inelastic cross section yeah I
can imagine from back there the green
and the white might look a little
similar yeah okay cool yeah like one of
these they give they give me a an almost
black one that's about as invisible as
it gets so make sure to use visible
colors okay so now let's take the case
of elastic neutron scattering and can
anyone tell me how can we simplify the
general hue equation for the case of
neutrons hitting some random nucleus
what can we start plugging in for some
of those values to make it simpler well
what about the masses what's M one in
atomic mass Q minutes M one is just one
to a pretty good approximation it's
actually 1.008 seven which we're going
to say is one and what about M 3 is also
yeah
also one if this is elastic neutron
scattering if the same Neutron goes in
and goes out so M 1 and M 3 are the same
thing
what about M 2 and M 4 have we specified
what this nucleus is so what's what mass
would we give it if it's a general
nucleus with and neutrons and Z protons
Hey sure so a that's again a 4 the mass
number cool ok
so with those in mind and then the last
thing is we only have T 1 and T 3 just
for clarity let's call T 1 T in like the
neutron energy going in and T 3 will
call T out so let's rewrite the Q
the QE q with these symbols in there and
the last thing to note what's Q for
elastic scattering zero yep because no
mass has turned into energy or vice
versa so to rewrite the whole Q equation
we've got zero equals T in times m1 over
m4 which is just 1 over a minus 1 plus T
out times 1 plus m3 / m4 m3 is also 1 m4
is also a and minus 2 root m1 m3 they're
both 1 T in T out cosine theta so this
looks a whole lot simpler I'm gonna do
one quick thing right here and take the
minus sign that's hiding in here outside
this equation it's going to make the
form a lot simpler so I'm just
multiplying the inside and the outside
of this term by negative 1 but hopefully
you can see that it's the same thing
it'll just make the form a lot nicer in
the end and so now we want to start
asking what is the maximum and minimum
energy that the neutron can lose so
let's start with the easy one what is
the minimum amount of energy that the
neutron could lose anyone not here's
some whispers zero if then if the
neutron comes in yeah theta equals zero
then you end up with actually TN will
equal T out and that way let's say delta
T 1 or delta T neutron could equal zero
so a neutron can lose at least none of
its energy in an elastic collision
hopefully that makes intuitive sense
because we would call that a Miss now
let's take the other case at what angle
would you think the neutron would
transfer as much energy as possible to
the recoil nucleus so if we have a big
nucleus of mass a and we have a little
Neutron firing at it at which angle does
it transfer the most energy yep exactly
at theta equals pi which means this we
call this back scattering so yeah good
good one if I'll correct your statement
though you said if the new if the
neutron just stops and the nucleus moves
forward does that happen in every case
okay for example if you were to and I'd
say don't try this at home kids put on a
nice helmet and run charging at a truck
can you actually just stop cold and
we're not assuming any bones breaking or
anything chances aren't you'd balance
right back off yeah that's the analogy I
like to give for what happens when a
neutron scatters off uranium it's like
running out of truck with a helmet on
it'll just bounce back so in the case of
theta equals PI so we're gonna
substitute in theta equals pi therefore
cosine theta equals negative 1 and we
have an even easier equation 0 equals
let's just say T out times 1 plus 1 over
a I'm going to arrange these terms in
order of their exponent for T out since
that's our variable again and if this
stuff is negative 1 then the two minus
signs cancel conveniently and we have
plus 2 root T in T out let's see that's
it and we have minus T in times 1 over 1
minus a
ideally we'd like to try to simplify
this as much as possible so let's
combine let's try to get everything in
some sort of a common denominator
because that would make things a lot
easier if we multiply each of these ones
by a over a so let's put that as a step
because we can totally do that we get 0
over T out times a over a plus 1 over a
plus 2 root T in T out minus T in times
a over a minus 1 over a at this point we
can well everything's in common terms
right we can just extend that fraction
sign and put the sign in here extend the
fraction sign put the sign in here we'll
just say that's a say that's a last step
that we'll do is try and isolate T out
so at least one of our quadratic factors
is going to be simple like 1
so next step divide by a plus 1 and then
we get 0 equals just T out plus 2 over a
plus 1 root T in T out minus T in times
a minus 1 over a plus 1 now we've got a
simple looking quadratic equation even
though it's quadratic in the square root
of T out yep let's see did I miss an A
or a dividing by a
it's from back here from this step just
these steps so you divide by a plus one
ah I see yeah you're right
though I want to make sure I didn't skip
a step in dividing an a let me just
check something real quick oh you're
right if we go back to our Q equation oh
let's see
there's an M for missing isn't there
that's it
ha see this is what happens when you
don't look at your notes okay I'll go
back and correct those because then
there should have been over a okay it
should have been an over a there should
have been an over a thank you for
pointing that out and there should have
been another oh in this case we can just
cancel all of the A's I knew it came out
nice and clean okay cool
so at this point this is a quadratic in
route T out where we have what are our a
B and C terms for this quadratic formula
so what's a first of all if it's a
quadratic and root t out
just one that was part of the goal of
this manipulation is to make at least
one of these things pretty simple what's
B 2 root Y n over a plus 1 and C is just
that whole term right there okay I'll do
this up here so then we can say root T
out equals negative B plus or minus the
square root of B squared so that's 4 TN
over a plus 1 squared minus 4 times a
times C so just minus 4 times C so minus
4 times negative T in a minus 1 over a
plus 1 so let's see what cancels so
first of all those minus signs cancel
and everything has a and over 2a don't
want to forget that over 2a which is
just 2 first thing we note is that
everything here has a 2 in it either
directly as a 2 or hiding as a square
root of 4 so we can cancel all of those
4 4 4 4
well make sure that minus sign is nice
and visible what else is common to
everything here
you
well I'll tell you what I'll write it
all out simpler without all the crossed
out stuff - root tea in over a plus one
plus or minus root tea in over a plus
one squared plus T in times a minus 1
over a plus one so with that a little
written a little simpler what's also
common and can be factored out of
everything that's right
square root of TN because there's a root
T in here and then you can everything's
got a TN inside the square root so you
can pull that out so we have a direct
relation between root T out and root TN
minus 1 over a plus 1 plus or minus root
1 over a plus 1 squared plus a minus 1
over a plus 1 what do we do here to
simplify all the junk in the square root
why the right side that's right you can
always multiply by something better
known as one and that gets everything
here just like there was a two or a root
for everywhere in the equation or there
was a routine and a root T and
everywhere else in the equation we'll do
the same thing to get the A plus one out
of there so we'll multiply this by a
plus 1 over a plus one I'll stick it
over there okay
and we get root T out equals now
everything has an A plus one so let's
bring all of those outside the fraction
root T in over a plus one times negative
1 plus or minus the square root of 1
plus a minus 1 a plus 1 starting to get
a lot simpler let's see how much if I
run out of space for this one so this
stuff right here is just a squared minus
a plus a minus 1 the minus a and the
plus a cancel out and then the plus 1
and the minus 1 cancel out and all
that's inside the square root is a
squared so the only hopefully nonlinear
board technique I'm going to move to the
left and we end up with roots t out
equals root T in over a plus 1 and all
that's left there is a minus 1 if we
take the positive root almost done just
square both sides and we should arrive
at a result that might look familiar to
some of you t out equals t in times a
minus 1 over a plus 1 squared and we've
gotten to the point
now where we can determine how much
energy the neutron can possibly lose or
the recoil nucleus can possibly gain in
an elastic collision it's this factor
right here I'll use the red since it's
more visible this is usually referred to
in nuclear textbooks as alpha the sort
of the maximum amount of energy a
neutron can lose or a recoil nucleus can
gain so what we've Dirk we've got what
we've arrived at is a pretty important
result that lets say the energy the
kinetic energy of a neutron has to be
between its initial kinetic energy and
alpha times its initial kinetic energy
this right here is one of the ways in
which you choose a moderator or a
slowing down medium for neutrons and
reactors
so it's this alpha factor right here
that really distinguishes what we call a
thermal or is it a a like a light water
reactor or a thermal spectrum reactor
from a spa fast spectrum reactor let's
look at a couple of limiting cases to
see why let's see anyone mind if I hide
this board here or you have a question
let's see right if we took the negative
case we'd end up with minus one minus a
you just have an A plus one on the top
yeah so in that case you just have let's
see you just have root T in right let me
see oh yeah so that wouldn't make very
much sense right yeah
so in that case well you don't want to
have a negative energy so that case
doesn't make physical sense thanks for
making sure we explained that and oh I
see another question yep okay so what I
did is I took the square root of four
out of every term inside the square root
and said okay they're all twos just like
in the next step I said alright there's
all these eight plus ones including all
these 8 + 1 squares inside the square
root and took that out or I think even
over here yeah so the whole theme here
has been combined and destroyed yep
any other questions on what we did here
before I go on to some of the
implications of what we got cool let's
look at a couple limiting cases I'll
rewrite that that inequality right there
because that's the important one of the
day so what is alpha for typical
materials let's say for hydrogen alpha
equals well it's always a minus 1 over a
plus 1 squared and for hydrogen a equals
1 equals 1 and then we have 1 minus 1 in
the numerator alpha equals zero what
this means is that for the case of
hydrogen you can lose all of the neutron
energy in a single collision
that doesn't mean that you lose all
energy in every collision with a
hydrogen atom if you're a neutron but it
means that you can lose up to all of
your energy in one single collision and
this is what makes hydrogen such a good
moderator or a slower down of neutrons
is one and undergoes elastic scattering
especially at energies below an MeV or
so which is where most of the neutrons
in the reactor are it just bounces
around and the more it hits hydrogen's
the more it imparts energy to those
hydrogen's and slows down why do we want
to slow the neutrons down in the first
place
well that has to do with another
cross-section that I'm going to draw if
I can find some chalk like I think I've
mentioned before every nuclear reaction
has its own cross section and this time
I'm going to introduce a new one called
Sigma fission the probability that if a
nucleus absorbs a neutron that it
undergoes fission and creates more
neutrons and like 200 MeV of recoil
energy so in this case I'll draw it for
you 235 since this is the one I pretty
much remember from memory and it looks
something like that so what you want is
for the neutrons to be at low energies
so this would be around the thermal
energy better-known is about 2002 5e v
your goal is that the more neutrons that
you have in this energy region the chalk
erases other chalk the more neutrons you
have in that energy region the higher
probability you have the fission so this
is the basis behind thermal reactors is
the neutrons all start here they're born
at around one to ten MeV they don't
undergo fission very well at one to ten
MeV so your goal as a thermal reactor
designer is to slow them down as
efficiently as possible what's the most
efficient way to slow down neutrons cram
the reactor full of hydrogen what's the
cheapest and most hydrogenous substance
we know water this is why water makes
such a good reactor moderator
it's pretty cool there's also lots of
other reasons that we use water it's
everywhere which is another way of
saying cheap it's pretty chemically
inert there are corrosion problems and
reactors but it doesn't just
spontaneously combust
when you see air like sodium does
another reactor coolant it takes a lot
of energy to heat it up so it's specific
heat capacity the CP of water if you
remember I think it's was it 4.184
joules per gram that's a point one of
the highest substances were that we know
of so you can put a lot of that recoil
energy or a lot of heat energy into this
water without raising its temperature as
much as a comparative substance metals
can have heat capacities like three or
four times lower so you wouldn't
necessarily want to use a metal coolant
or would you in what cases would you
want to use a metal coolant for a
reactor or has anyone ever heard of
liquid metal reactors before just a
couple good I get to be the first one to
tell you I did my whole PhD on alloys
for the liquid lead reactor so let's
take a look at lead which has an a of
about let's call it 200 it's like I
think there's some isotopes like 203 or
so there's probably an isotope called
lead 200 what would alpha be for lead
well let's just plug in the numbers a
minus 1 is 199 a plus 1 is 201 square
that almost 1 almost this means that
when neutrons hit something like lead
they basically don't slow down they can
lose at least none and at most almost
none of their energy and this is the
basis behind what's called fast reactors
if you want to use a coolant that keeps
the neutrons very fast because for
uranium 238 there's what's called a well
what you do is you want to capture
neutrons with uranium 238 make plutonium
239 and then breed that
or uranium-238 has got its fast fission
cross-section and i don't think i want
to get into bringing it on the screen
today since we're almost 5 of 5 off what
I will say is there's lots of other
reactor coolant besides water and it
sounds to me like almost no one had
heard of a liquid metal reactor why
would you want to use a liquid metal as
a coolant besides keeping the neutrons
at high energy anyone have any ideas
what sort of properties do you want out
of a coolant not even for a reactor but
for anything good heat transfer metals
are extremely thermally conductive so if
you want to get the heat out of the fuel
rods and into the coolant and then out
to make steam for a turbine liquid
metals are a pretty awesome coolant to
use because they conduct heat extremely
well what else let's try and think now
if you were a reactor designer you don't
just have to make the reactor work but
you want to make it avoid accidents
what sort of thermodynamic properties
about metals could prevent accidents
from happening yeah so there's one
problem they could solidify so coolants
that have been chosen four reactors have
been things like sodium which melts just
below a hundred Celsius liquid lead
bismuth which melts at a hundred twenty
three Celsius and I know cuz I've melted
it in a frying pan before so I did four
years of research on liquid led bismuth
and if there's anyone that's gotten
enough exposure to that it's me does not
seem to have affected my brain too much
because I only made like two major
mistakes on today's board good enough
yeah so I've got hundreds of pounds of
led business sitting around it's pretty
inert stuff it's really dense so it can
store a lot of heat the other thing is
the boiling point anyone know what
temperature metals boil at extremely
high yep
sodium boils at approximately exactly
893 degrees Celsius liquid led bismuth
that boils out approximately exactly
1607
Celsius you'll actually melt the steel
that the reactor is made of before you
boil off your coolant if you boil your
your coolant you have no way of cooling
the reactor and that's something you
want to avoid water boils at
approximately 325 - let's say 288 to 340
Celsius depending on the pressure that's
used in the reactors and that does get
reached sometimes especially in accident
conditions so if you want to make
something relatively Fukushima proof
then you don't want the coolant to boil
so use a liquid metal which introduces
other problems it also introduces some
other problems I'm gonna flash forward a
bit to neutrons and reactor design
because it does take time for this react
this scattering to happen these
collisions they happen pretty quickly
but they do take a finite amount of time
and in the mean time you can have what's
called feedback coefficients natural
bits of physics that help your reactors
stay stable or they don't depending on
what's called negative or positive
feedback so we can have either negative
or positive feedback I'll give you one
simple example that I'll just introduce
conceptually and will actually explain
it a little mathematically later in the
course let's talk about coolant density
if you were to heat up your reactor and
the coolant were to get less dense what
do you think would happen to the
reaction rate of well anything
scattering fission absorption it should
go down why do you think that is exactly
yeah to reintroduce a bit of the
cross-section stuff I mentioned last
time the microscopic cross-section is
the probability that let's say one
nucleus hits one other nucleus if you
then multiply by the number density or
how many of them are there you end up
with the macroscopic cross section so
I'll label this is micro label this is
macro and then the macroscopic
cross-section times your Neutron flux
gives you your reaction rate so if you
want to get less moderating happening or
less fission or less absorption the
simplest way is well that's a property
of the material that's whatever your
reactor is doing you can decrease the
number density by heating things up and
decrease in the density so this is one
of those cases where you can use the
reactor to quickly respond with physics
before you could respond with human
intervention if you want let's say a
extra power transient or a sudden
increase in heat to slow down the
nuclear reaction and not speed it up
you'd pick a moderator that behaves in
this way so in this case water would get
less dense it would moderate less well
and put fewer neutrons in the high
probability fission region then let's
think about what happens if you're
depending on your neutrons to stay fast
or at high energy let's say you were to
have a really bad day and boil your
liquid sodium all of a sudden what
little moderating power exists in that
sodium disappears or gets even lower and
that would cause your reactor power to
increase so one of the dangers of fast
spectrum reactors is positive what's
called positive void coefficient or if
you make a bubble of gaseous sodium your
power increases rather than decreases
that would increase the heat that would
cause the power to go up that would
increase the heat that would cause the
power to go up luckily there are many
many other negative feedback mechanisms
that could be built in to make sure the
overall feedback coefficients are still
negative
this also lets us understand a little
bit about what went wrong at Chernobyl
and I'll give you a one minute
flash-forward because the control rods
that were made of let's see I don't
remember what than what the composition
of the control rods is but they were
Neutron absorbers the control rods in
Chernobyl
looked something like this where there
was the absorber here and this was they
were graphite tipped and as you lower
that graphite down into the reactor
you're all of a sudden introducing
something well that's a okay moderator
for
Carbon let's say a equals 12 so our
alpha is would be a minus 1 over a plus
1 I'm not gonna write almost equal to 1
because that isn't quite almost equal to
1 what does this actually equal let's
see let's just say definitely less than
1 there is some moderating power to
graphite it's also a very bad absorber
and what this meant that as you lowered
those control rods into the reactor you
suddenly introduced a little more
moderation when things were already
going bad and that caused the power
level to increase further there were
other problems like it was designed so
that if you boiled some of the coolant
you would have positive feedback and
that is a sort of 1-minute synopsis is
what one all went haywire at Chernobyl
but we'll be doing a look
second-by-second or in some cases
millisecond by millisecond play of what
went wrong with Chernobyl and we could
probably do the same for Fukushima now
now that we understand what happened
based on the physics you'll be learning
in this course and this is actually a
perfect stopping point because next up
we're gonna be looking at the different
processes of radioactive decay many of
which are a simplification of this Q
equation and I think some of which are
probably familiar to you guys because
radiation decay is part of the normal
lexicon especially nowadays so since
it's 5:05 of do you guys have any
questions on what we've covered so far
yep
[Music]
yep it's actually it's so you're asking
about if the water feedback is part of
the backup that's your primary line of
defense your backup is human
intervention because compared to physics
humans are really really slow like many
orders of magnitude slower it takes
microseconds for things to thermally
expand it definitely takes more than
seconds for a human to respond anyone
ever done those tests where you have a
light blinking and you have to hit a
button the second you see the light
what's the fastest any of you guys have
ever responded anyone remember anyone
beat a second maybe tenth of a second
and there all you have to do is hit a
button all you have to do is hit the
only button when you see the only light
what if you're piloting something that's
about as complicated as the Space
Shuttle but more likely to explode what
do you think your reaction time will be
you'll know probably long you'll
probably have to pull out the manual and
probably you'll have to RTFM for a
little while and maybe you'll find out
what you have to do and maybe you won't
so it's actually operator error that has
caused most of the near misses or actual
misses in nuclear reactors the physics
except for the Russian RBMK design that
would froze for Chernobyl usually it's
human error that's the downfall of these
things so by understanding the physics
here we can rely on it to keep things
safe yes good question how do you cool
the liquid lead you can't send liquid
lead through a turbine right so at some
point you've got to make steam and use
that to drive a turbine you can use
what's called a heat exchanger at its
simplest you could think of it like a
couple of tubes or the lead is going
through here and the steam is going
through here
and they have a very thin barrier
between them so you have all this heat
moving from the lead which is hotter to
the steam which is colder they actually
have built a bunch of these lead
reactors yep
the Russian fast attack subs the alpha
class subs were powered by and are
powered by liquid lead reactors they're
the only reactors that can outrun a
torpedo so when you have a liquid lead
reactor powering and you've got a panic
button that says forget the safety
systems outrun the torpedo you have a
choice between maybe dying in a reactor
explosion and definitely getting shot
out of the water with a torpedo
you do whatever you can and these subs
only run two or three knots slower than
a torpedo so just like that old algebra
problem if this guy leaves Pittsburgh at
8 a.m. traveling 40 miles an hour and
I've trying to get to Boston 30 miles an
hour if a sub if a torpedo leaves one
sub moving this velocity and the alpha
attack sub senses it from this distance
and starts moving at a similar velocity
chances are the torpedo runs out of
steam before it reaches the alpha sub
and that's only because they can have an
extremely compact liquid lead nuclear
reactor at the power source good
question how do you use the Lihue you
move the liquid lead you can move it by
natural convection but that's extremely
slow so there are multiple ways of
moving it one of the cool ones is called
an e/m or electromagnetic pump it
induces eddy currents in the liquid lead
because it's also a conductor and those
eddy currents couple with the EM field
from the e/m pump and cause the lead to
start moving on its own so it's a no
moving parts pump the only problem is
it's like 1 or 2 percent efficient yeah
so they don't use those on the subs but
you can use eemm pumps to move
conductive coolants that's true I think
it's pretty awesome then there have
there have been land submarines in fact
there's a company called Acme
engineering in Russia that's trying to
commercialize a small modular liquid
lead reactor the other nice thing about
these liquid metal coolants is you can
make the reactors much much smaller and
denser than in a light water reactor and
the light water reactor you're relying
on a lot
water to cool things and a lot of water
to be there to moderate your neutrons in
a liquid metal reactor where you don't
need moderation well you don't need all
you need is enough coolant to keep
things cool so you can tighten stuff up
and make it more compact so that's one
of the nuclear startups coming out
nowadays this is an awesome time to be
in nuclear when I started nuclear there
were approximately exactly zero nuclear
startups like Terra power didn't even
exist yet
now there's something like 52 in the US
and others around the world so like this
is the time to be in nuclear if you're
up for startups and not just working in
academia or a lab or a big corporation
there's a lot of little companies now
doing some crazy things based on some
pretty good physics so maybe time for
one more question before I let you guys
go if not then I'll see you guys on
Tuesday when we start radioactive decay